Would you rather be dressed by Rudy Giuliani for a year
or never have access to contraceptive ever again?
Haha,
give me Rudy styling, Rudy Giuliani dressing.
Rudy Giuliani could dress me.
Fuck, we don't trust Rudy Giuliani style.
No, too scary.
Too scary. I don't want him, like,
knowing my body or thinking about my body,
you know what I mean? People have to know that he's dressing me.
Or would it have to be a secret?
Because it doesn't matter.
I would figure out a way to rock it.
Ultimately, you would do anything rather than ban contraceptives?
I'm here for my girlies and I'm here for who needs it.
So doing it for the cause.
Yes. I would want everybody else on contraceptive,
but table for the team, only Giuliani.
Trust me. Forever.
If it meant that women have access to contraceptives forever.
Are you wearing the bald cap? Never say no.